[Music]
I think that history is a way of dealing
with data so one of the one of the
things I'm really struck by when I give
lectures in Silicon Valley for example
or when I talk to people who are doing
things I'm very impressed by and I'm not
going to say that you know I completely
understand them right
but one of the things I'm struck by is a
certain kind of naivete that data
automatically produces knowledge which
it doesn't I mean at all right I mean
the total amount of data in the universe
is the total amount of data in the
universe how we choose to conceptualize
it
categorize it that's that's up to us and
creating creating larger and larger
larger larger databases doesn't actually
solve that problem on the contrary I
mean it can persuade people that
quantity is somehow gonna automatically
become quality which just isn't so it's
it's just not true and I mean one of the
things I've become a little bit stuck on
or even obsessed with is the idea that
people who are for example going to be
computer science majors are engineering
majors should hat take some kind of
humanities minor that there should be
like a history or philosophy or whatever
a minor a major so that they don't stop
thinking about the questions of right
and wrong or the questions of the
questions of the how and the law the
questions of the why and not just the
how because people who are very
accomplished in fields that involve data
I mean though I'm gonna put this very
directly
they often sound very naive when they
talk about questions of of why and you
and you get and this is true of people
who've made a lot of money in fields
involving data as well they get to a
point where they can have a great deal
of influence on the world but often I
can I'm just gonna be very direct about
this the way they talk about the world
and the way they're gonna exercise
influence it on it can be startlingly
naive from a humanities point of view
they're going to be whole swathes of the
world which they think they see but they
really don't and there's a whole second
problem here which I'm going
going to name and you can do with it
what you want and that is the way that
we are data producers and not just data
consumers I think that freedom involves
the ability to know something about how
your own data is being used or one way
in the 20th century to think about
freedom is what's the balance between
the data I'm I'm unknowingly launching
out into the world all the time and the
data that's coming back at me you know
one way to think about the current risk
of unfreedom in this country and
generally is I'm leaking all kinds of
objective stuff which can be used
against me I mean if in trivial ways
like by giving me a worse hotel room or
whatever but also in significant ways by
targeting political messages to me but
what's coming back to me may be very
subjective in the sense that it's
designed to manipulate how I how I see
the world right getting that balance
right it I think is essential to freedom
I mean some of the stuff that launches
out from me should not just be data
that's going to allow people to run
protocols to figure out how to
manipulate me some of the stuff that
comes out for me should be like what's
really good for me and some of the stuff
that comes back to me shouldn't just be
these manipulative
you know indices it should be the facts
that I actually need to be a good
citizen that's it you know for me like
that's an interesting balance between
humanities and technology and what I've
noticed is that since we don't think
about it this way we basically punted on
the whole question by accepting this
politics of inevitability that the
Internet's going to mean enlightenment
more data means better understanding and
so on because we put on that question we
find ourself I think in a very
precarious position where the humans are
actually just kind of holding on by
their fingernails to a sense of you know
being individuals well a whole lot of
you know data is basically being used
against them all the time so trying to
find again I want to be a fatalist about
this I think it can be solved but I
think thinking about it that way like as
a balance where the data that comes out
of me
you know has to has to be governed by
some notion of Rights and I would also
say the data that comes back at me
has to be governed by some notion of
rights I mean I think people do you have
a basic right of access to factuality or
maybe we should be thinking about a
basic right of access to factuality
because without that without like access
to data that makes sense to an average
citizen at the right time it's very hard
to have any of the other rights or the
other rights I think are very hard to
maintain
[Music]
you